let's go back to UM the movie though um
oh yes yeah so anyway it's uh don't give
any spoilers spoilers should watch and
watch it yeah it's actually a cute
little movie it's not very cute it's
actually very scary it's scary but it
cute in the way that like oh my god this
is such a simple kind of a premise but
it's super fun to watch and it's well
executed in that way cute Oh ten million
only Wow
ten million debate yeah oh wow that's
amazing great job that's amazing because
everything is set in one house yeah in
the middle of you know Detroit well you
know it's supposed to be in Detroit
where do you guys rank it for this year
of scary films I think that guys it's
not it's not uh it's it's a I don't even
know what to categorize it there's two
it says more of a thriller yeah it is a
thriller cuz for me what I find it's
it's like it jolts you right because the
scenes are thrilling and suspenseful but
what what scares me to my core are never
movies that involve real humans it's
always like like spiritual like
possessions or you know The Exorcist
ghosts and things like that that really
shaped me yeah inside like other I mean
the movie don't breathe is more like
it's just jolting it's like you scream
cuz you know it's suspense what's like a
saw there's no yeah it's a really good
tight is a slasher movie around me a
movie called a simple plan you ever see
that movie yes oh my god love that
movement is very good movie a simple
plan its I could you state a premise
that's you know basic and but it's just
executed in a well way the dialogues
good but there's a kid in that movie
that's a store I don't know his name but
young kid yeah yeah yeah I forget who he
was very him and I don't want to give
anything away but can I just get it into
the premise a little bit or not uh well
it's just basically this I'm not gonna
read ya I'm not gonna get I'm not giving
away anything you know it's not gonna be
like a sixth sense that Bruce Willis is
really dead kind of a thing and if you
haven't if it's in a sense you should do
you should watch it by now but he it's
about three kids in from Michigan they
happen to be white
and they decide to rob a blind demand
and that's pretty much their the premise
don't do that and what's great about the
movie is that you don't feel you feel
bad you don't feel that bad about these
kids because they put themselves in this
situation
oh so you're rooting for the guy no
you're not yeah in the beginning I was I
was rooting for the guy yeah but they
deserve it they shouldn't have entered
your home but that's what makes it fun
and that's why the extreme things that
blind he's blind to the man the blind
man does is uh wait a minute
seems kind of blah I mean if I robbed a
blind man's house I'm walking out
whatever I know because it's blind man
number one he's also the sergeant from
Avatar like he says he's the buffest 70
year old blind Manuel is a military
buddy
yeah oh [ __ ] so he's in the military
right and also he has he lives by
himself and he has a lot of issues and
mainly his issue is that his daughter
was murdered that's all I need to know
yeah sleeps with his daughters taped
like a videotape on like a loop and his
eyes are just completely white fried and
rot white he's broken he's broken he
feels broken yeah he has emotional mom I
know but the way they did that was
pretty good man pretty good yeah that's
good those kids are really talented
what's his name fede alvarez the guy who
directed it
[Music]